you're telling me you can't be on the
top of the charts cuz Drake the are
you talking about I'm just happy for
everyone cuz everyone can eat the second
I know someone can't win is the second
they start telling me that someone else
is eating their food I'm like you're
done you're telling me you can't be on
the top of the charts cuz Drake the
are you talking about like then ice
spice couldn't happen because Meg the
stallion happened but Meg couldn't
happen cuz cardi happened but wait cardi
couldn't happen because Nikki had like
enough of this my friends once
and for all you want to be happier start
realizing that everything that isn't
working is on you ain't no one taking
your